it's your decision your grace but if
we're gonna be allies in this war it's
important for the northerners to see us
as allies if we sail to white Harbor
together I think it sends a better
message we sailed together hey everybody
we got new Game of Thrones to talk about
this is actually a reload because there
was like a little bit that there was
some confusion about so I wanted to
clarify about the origin of Jon Snow's
name as well as some of the big battles
that are going to be happening during
season eight some of them we know about
but there's some new evidence to suggest
some interesting stuff for the final
battle so there's a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so I'll start with a little
bit of history for some of the other new
locations - like white Harbor the really
cool thing is that the stark that
effectively established white Harbor as
an outpost for House Stark was named
John Stark that was right before the war
of conquest
so when Aegon conquer the Seven Kingdoms
the Stark who knelt the king of the
north was named Tauron stark so that was
his descendant before that the king in
the north was named John Stark Jo N so
while John Snow was directly named for
Jon Arryn people that were close to Ned
Stark you get an idea where that John
name came from it wasn't like they were
going outside the family he was still
giving him a stark name albeit with an
interesting origin so that kind of gives
you an idea for where Ned Stark came up
with the name John when it was time to
name the baby obviously we know that his
name is supposed to be Aegon so he had
to come up with a different name to
disguise who he was so now we know he
didn't just pull it out of thin air so
it makes sense that the name John flows
through the stark family names recur all
the time like Brandon Brandon the
Builder Brandon present-day Brandon that
was Ned Stark's older brother so before
the war of conquest eventually sea
Raiders who started to use that as a
landing point for incursions so the king
in the north John Stark built a fort
there called the Wolf's den it's still
there today but as with all things in
the big cities of Game of Thrones and
Westeros the old fort became impractical
so they built a new castle literally
called the new castle that eventually
became the seed of house Manderley and
they turned the Wolf's den this old fort
that was near the waterfront into a
prison there were first men that used to
live in this area and an even smaller
settlement but they really just used it
as a small ring for like there's a rock
called seal Rock that just crowned with
a ring fort it's just this really
primitive structure but by the time they
got to the war of conquest it had been
abandoned for centuries so if we get to
see some of these structures when Jon
Snow Daenerys land there during season 8
they'll probably accomplish that with a
little bit of CG I'm not expecting them
to spend too much time in White Harper
because they're trying to get everybody
to Winterfell that will probably happen
during the course of the first episode
so you're literally talking them a
landing and then sort of like a cross
cut to them rolling up to Winterfell so
like just a big time jump somewhere in
the episode white Harbor itself is right
down here next to moat Cailin so when
it's not snowing like the world's going
to end it looks a little bit like the
weather you'd see around moat Cailin
although it's not nearly quite as boggy
the interesting thing about that is that
didn't always use to look like that it
looked like the rest of the north until
the children of the forest during the
war with the first men try to crack
Westeros in half using the hammer of
waters again unsuccessfully in what
ended up happening is is they caused
this big flood that turned the area of
this big boggy mire so you just have to
picture the children of the forest
literally trying to break this continent
in half right down here right below
greywater watch along this line here but
there have actually been a number of
other houses before house Manderly to
hold white Harbor
there were Flint's locks slates Long's
Holtz ash woods the manderlys only took
up residence some time before the war of
conquest when one of the Gardiner kings
drove them out of the reach because
their previous seat was down here in
Dustin burry so you have to imagine
house manderley the manderley so you get
the idea but ever since the conquest
they've held white Harbor and then
obviously you imagined what happened to
house Gardner during the conquest that
was the end of their house as well but
moving to a different location they're
building out a lot of big castle sets at
their Belfast location where their big
main studio is they do a lot of interior
shoots there where they have to
do special effects or anything that's
really weird that they can't do at the
big practical sets where they would film
all their big kings landing scenes a lot
of those locations are protected
historical area so like if they want to
do a big battle they have to be careful
not to destroy anything so they have to
film the really hardcore stuff back at
their studio so a bunch of trebuchet
--zz have showed up outside what looks
like their King's Landing set that
they're building so it sounds like
they're preparing for a big final battle
with Daenerys army because they were the
last army we saw using trebuchet during
season 4 during the siege of Marine so
it sounds like someone's either going to
besieging King's Landing or the
trebuchet salon to Cersei and she's
going to be using them against the army
of the Dead so timeline refresher they
just started doing their cast
read-throughs of the final scripts and
started shooting with the actors but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're going to be shooting the scenes
in order so like if they have a big
battle scene to film that requires a lot
of big practical sets that they have to
build they start doing that right away
they actually give all of the scripts as
necessary to the production crew that
have to build the sets and do the
costumes and all of those things before
they give them to the actors because it
doesn't necessarily matter what the
characters are saying the people that
have to make all the stuff that they use
in the show have to know about that
ahead of time because it takes a lot
longer to build so that's why you saw
them start building out the Winterfell
set they're building out a bigger facade
so they can film exterior shots for
Winterfell big army scenes way back
right as season seven was ending before
they'd even finished the scripts for
Season eight there's always gonna be a
couple really easy things they know
they're definitely going to need and
will require a ton of extra time like
the big quarry set that they built for
season seven episode six
they literally built themselves a lake
which explains a little bit about how
they wrote in Reverse like okay we're
gonna have a big scene here so how do we
get the characters there it might have
only taken them six months to film the
season but it took way longer than that
to actually build that lake but will
might end up happening for the big
scenes at places like the karhold or the
last hearth places where you know the
army of the Dead is probably going to
come first is that they'll just film
some small exterior shots
where they give it sort of a Highgarden
treatment where it might not be a big
prolonged battle because they're not
that many people there so it doesn't
make sense to blow their wad on really
small locations they're just so a big
action set piece of the night King just
spraying everything with magic blue fire
but pending them building more big sets
that we haven't seen yet confirm huge
battle at Winterfell confirm huge battle
at King's Landing which makes a lot of
sense given where the show started but
as we learn a little bit more we can
talk more about what might be happening
in those big battles let me know in the
comments though what big battle do you
actually think is going to be happening
at King's Landing like will it be
Cersei versus the army of the Dead or
will it be a situation where Jon Snow
and Daenerys are able to defeat the
night king earlier in the season and
then they bring their armies south for a
big final battle with Cersei I think a
lot of people were hoping that the final
battle would be something with the Nike
but there's a lot of evidence that
seemingly suggests that might not be the
case but a lot of that still speculation
so what will happen is is I'll have new
Game of Thrones this week I'll announce
the giveaway winner when I post that
there's new Walking Dead posting tonight
there's some surprise stuff that just
drops so I might do a video for that
I've have enough time to but while you
wait for everything you can click here
to listen to sir Davos explain what
their episode schedule is going to be
and you can click here to learn about
the new cast they use so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight